j'ai pas une poule 1 alors pardon
on
[Musique]
pardon pourrait répéter un petit le plus
fort ce courrier est bien monsieur le
sénateur vous venez de dire parce que
des fois que ce serait pas aux jauges
des eaux vous venez de dire à mon propos
pendant que je parlais de la parité
c'est qui cette nana je souhaite que
soit qu'un inscrit vous avez gagné
peut-être ce matin la palme du misogyne
bof de cette assemblée
[Musique]
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
notamment ça suffit mais qui sait qu'ici
fait côté heureusement j'ai pas une
poule 1 c'est bon il ya des
comportements que trois hommes des
cotisations
[Musique]
monsieur le président à l'écouté
mesdames et messieurs les députés mais
surtout messieurs visiblement
[Musique]
si elle n'est pas là simplement pour les
apparences merci servir de pots de
fleurs elles doivent émerger à nos
débats et venir nous rejoindre
[Musique]
tu es abattu un des bars et des cafés
tabac café tabac
[Musique]
vous me permettrez madame la ministre de
vous féliciter pour le choix de la
couleur de votre tailleur le verre ou va
effectivement à merveille